former President Jimmy Carter today
remains in home Hospice Care in Plains
Georgia one week after the Carter Center
announced that the 98 year old will
spend his remaining time at home with
his family since then many of his
admirers have flocked to the
southwestern Georgia area to pay tribute
and to reflect on the simple beginnings
of a man who has had a global impact
here's Robert Costa
who is Jimmy Carter the answer might
begin here in the Red Dirt of archery
Georgia just down the road from his
current home in Plains and where
chickens and goats still roam around
under pecan trees this is the boyhood
home of the nation's 39th president when
we first got the news other folks that
are out here the volunteers and all we
got kind of a lump in our throat
National Park Service guide Sandra
Seacrest has welcomed the well-wishers
who have come since the former president
made his decision to enter home Hospice
Care has it been tough
in the last few days since President
Carter announced his decision to come
home the people that are coming through
now are saying what a wonderful man he
is and how much he's given and although
they may not have agreed completely with
his politics at the time they all talk
about serving as an example for the way
people should treat others and that they
just want to be here and and be close to
those those values that he he holds dear
Carter lived here from when he was four
years old until when he left for the U.S
Naval Academy Carter has been Frank
about his upbringing and about how his
black neighbors faced racial segregation
including from his own family well Daddy
was like every other adult that I ever
knew in those days was a segregationist
Carter has credited his mother Lillian a
nurse who later served in the Peace
Corps for treating both black and white
people and for encouraging him to live a
life of leadership and service and
Carter do Solomon I swear I Jimmy Carter
do solemnly swear that I will Faithfully
execute that I will Faithfully execute
the office of President of the United
States the office of President of the
United States but the call of Home
brought Carter and his wife Rosalind
back after they left the White House
says their longtime friend Jill Stuckey
what has planes meant for them
it's it's everything it's home it's
family it's friends it's their church
it's where they returned to when they've
been all over the world and want peace
they're working for peace all over the
world but they find it here the Carter's
connection to this Farm his Boyhood Farm
remains to this day in fact the eggs
that are laid here in this chicken coop
are personally delivered to the former
president and the former first lady
Rosalind Carter down the road in fact
his friends say that one of his favorite
dishes remains scrambled eggs and bacon
sometimes even for dinner for CBS
Saturday morning Robert Costa archery
Georgia
I'll never forget producer video singing
I went to Sunday school to see him to to
witness what he gave to his church
members at Maranatha and um back in 2015
when they discovered his brain cancer
and it was just such a delight to be
there didn't get a chance to really talk
to him but oh what a sermon I love that
he still gets to enjoy his scrambled
eggs oh yeah for dinner and it is
interesting politics are put aside yeah
people to remember saying goodbye so
many things that he has done